tough about like for me something it was
something new
because
back home like growing up like you know
for us relationships kind of we built in
something together from scratch
so you met your you know a man it
doesn't have probably nothing as you
don't and in together we we built
together so
that's the way in which i
see relationships so i don't i can
obviously pretend from a guy to you know
okay be a billionaire right
do you think girls only care they only
don't care if they can't get the guys
that are rich
they don't care like i feel like girls
only don't care about money if they
can't get the guys that are successful i
always been like that even in my 20s and
i actually was as you said you know my
best i actually been for long with in a
relationship on my 20s and i decided to
leave the guy
so and that guy wasn't that he was rich
rich no he wasn't oh he wasn't but
that's what i said
i'm saying like if you have a guy i
actually didn't date a rich person to
stay with a broken woman
yeah that's probably why i didn't
why if you dated a rich person no i said
i had like
honestly speaking at the beginning when
i met my ex-boyfriend i date once a guy
who was richer than him
six foot tall
footballer oh anyway good looking
and i actually prefer
my the one day after became my boyfriend
that wasn't six foot he wasn't rich i
was a footballer you know i mean i
actually pick him
as if you ask me why that's also reason
why don't you stay
with the this guy because growing up i
was
25 when i left him i had a different
plan from him
so i decided to leave the country to you
know develop my career study
he actually followed me but at some
point for me i just decided he wasn't
the guy yeah but
so it's kind of like you picked him but
you didn't you picked him for a little
bit but then you didn't pick him
six years now little bit probably is
more than some marriage he's with him
for six years yes
that's like scarier to guys though
because it's like you stayed with him
for six years in the left
i'm just like no i think i just i think
it's scary if a woman is the same woman
science i mean from her 20s sis six of
signs she get 40. you cannot be the same
person when you're 20 and when you're
40. if that is the case
you know growing up like you cannot be
the same person at 20 and in your 40s so
i think i actually
you know i had a development
and and this could happen that you know
the development didn't match my guy
development so you know we just end up
in different do you feel your values the
same when you're 20 and then when you
hit to 40. again we i think i already
asked this question like i already
answered
uh
if i mean from my side the value is not
about
be young be pretty and be virgin
the value is about the topics that you
can come out with is about your
knowledge is about what you can do by
your own uh is about what have you done
like
in those 30 years what have you done if
you study every work what have you
actually built
in your life what do you have
that's like
that's that's man though that's like
what women want for them i don't know
yeah no no that's what girls do is they
become the men they want to marry
so like all because
whenever i was being like that even on
my 20s yeah i'm not yeah i mean a lot of
girls are because feminism feeds women a
lie
because i mean the least happy
demographic of women is 45 single and
childless
and and it's like what does your career
matter if you don't have someone to
share it with like i could be a
multi-billionaire and if i came home to
an empty house my life means nothing
that is like the set like and then it's
like like what you need to focus on
yourself all the time you run into your
big house and hug your dogs and you're
over the moon no because like life is
not about just about i
not at the opposite way i'm kind of
scared about those women that they focus
everything in
their
marriage and their children because at
the end yeah why because at the end like
at some point you're just a human being
you need to be focused also on your on
yourself not when you have a family you
have some needs no because when you're
when you're a mother when you're
when you're
when you're a mother it's not about you
anymore it's like your kids happiness
comes first but it's like if you're it's
if you can't put your kids before
yourself like yeah you probably
shouldn't have kids yeah but many people
i think we are agreeing i think many
people actually ask they decide to have
i think girls decide not to have kids
because they can't get a guy that they
want to have kids with
i think because most girls if i talk to
them if they said if this if you found a
guy that checked all your boxes would
you have kids with them the answer is
generally yes yeah
so to me it's that they can't acquire
the men that they want and the men that
they want don't want them
but you said that already yeah you said
that earlier
i've heard that i've heard that from
women
i've heard that from women and they'd
rather die alone or like just be alone
yeah right i feel like yeah
when you start talking
oh yeah when you start talking about
being an independent woman and what you
bring to the table and if he can't match
that i'm fine to be alone what you're
saying is
okay
i can't find a man i want so i'm going
to be alone yes
exactly
because i don't see like the need for a
woman right now in 2022 to add other men
next to you like i don't because i'm i'm
not looking for a man who can provide me
financially i don't look for a man who
can protect me
so like my man must be my friend
what if he was a bum he could protect
you be a bum like he doesn't work
you're not looking for him to provide
yeah yeah but i i i made the point very
clear like i want someone that is like i
still like yeah it must be like my
friend it must have focused like me like
exactly like kind of me but obviously
you know the yeah but
like
so in a way you do you did become the
man you wanted to marry yeah you you can
actually say that yeah and it's it's
like almost sad to me because i feel
like you actually think like that's what
men want in terms of like a career woman
and they just don't care
like would you date a girl without a job
yeah
did you marry a girl without a job yeah
yeah but we
coming back to the same point it's free
to do whatever as i i'm free to stay by
my own yeah because i'm not sad as you
think i got i go anyway family i got
niece and nephew you're right i got a
job
i'm taking actually a lot of a lot of um
i'm happy i mean you're also you're also
beautiful
and so so like but beauty runs out at
some point and when beauty runs out the
attention stuff
when beauty runs out the attention stops
because nobody's knocking on your door
at 60. no one's knocking on your door at
50. i wouldn't and like life is lonely
after 45 if you don't have a family i
wouldn't at low my sunder and i wouldn't
accept a man who thinks i should just be
in the kitchen washing dishes i'm not
saying don't be lonely i honestly prefer
being lonely for the rest of my life
then keep myself my ass in the kitchen
washing dishes most men don't care if
you have a job like most men if you want
you want to have kids no no i'm saying
i'm saying most men can't even afford to
have you washing dishes in the kitchen
yeah so most men aren't going to require
that of you but what i'm saying is like
if you don't prioritize family it's
going to be lonely and